يقول في منشوره الاجتماعي الحقيقي نقلاً عن
الرئيس السابق للولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية سيتم القبض عليه يوم الثلاثاء من
الأسبوع المقبل احتجاجًا على استعادة أمتنا، هل
يتكهن عميلك بشأن
الاعتقال للتحريض على العنف السياسي،
لا أعتقد أنه يتكهن على الإطلاق.
أعتقد أن هذا هو السبب وراء قيامك
بتغطيتها في أعلى الساعة، أعني
أننا جميعًا نسمعها ونسمع جميعًا
تسريبات من المدعي العام وهو أمر
نموذجي جدًا، لذا فإن عدم معالجة شيء كهذا
سيكون أمرًا غير مسؤول، فهو
مرشح للرئاسة وهو
رئيس سابق، يقوم شخص ما بتسريب
أنه سيتم القبض عليه،
نسمع عن اجتماعات نسمع
عن أشخاص يذهبون إلى هيئة المحلفين الكبرى
بمعلومات، سمعنا بالفعل كذبة
عن شخص يقول إنهم ذهبوا إلى هيئة المحلفين
الكبرى  هيئة المحلفين ولم يفعلوا ذلك، كيف لا يمكنه
تناول الأمر، إنه شخصية سياسية رئيسية
وليس شخصية سياسية،
لذلك أعتقد أنها ليست تكهنات، إنها
شيء نسمعه
وأنا سعيد لأنه تناوله لأنه
إذا كان صحيحًا  عليه أن يستبق
الأمر، محامي الرئيس السابق
ترامب يلوم وسائل الإعلام على ادعاء ترامب
بأنه سيتم القبض عليه يوم الثلاثاء في
مانهاتن، في تصريح لشبكة CNN،
يقول جو تاكابينا إنه لا أحد يخبرنا بأي شيء
وهو أمر محبط للغاية
يستند إليه الرئيس ترامب.  رده على
التقارير الصحفية وحقيقة أن هذه
محاكمة سياسية وأن المدعي العام يسرب
الأشياء إلى الصحافة بدلاً من
التواصل مع المحامين كما
ينبغي الآن بدأت هذه الدراما في وقت سابق
اليوم على صفحة ترامب الحقيقة الاجتماعية بعد
توقع اعتقاله يوم الثلاثاء
السابق  حث الرئيس مؤيديه على
الاقتباس "استعادة أمتنا"، والليلة تقوم
حملته بالفعل بجمع التبرعات
من مزاعمه التي لم يتم
تأكيدها، وليس هناك ما يشير إلى أنه
سيتم القبض عليه يوم الثلاثاء. الآن
تخبرني المصادر وزميلتي كريستين هولمز
أن فريق ترامب القانوني قد حصل على  لا توجد
كلمة
لمكتب المدعي العام لمنطقة مانهاتن حول توقيت
أي لائحة اتهام محتملة، ويقول مصدر آخر إن
الرئيس السابق كان
يضغط على فريقه لإثارة غضب القاعدة
بسبب الفكرة لأنه يعتقد أنها
ستساعده سياسيًا
في الخارج